[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravie de vous retrouver
dans Parlement Hebdo le meilleur de la
semaine parlementaire à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat on va découvrir
les séquences fortes avec notre invité
que nous présente Alexandre bonjour
Alexandre bonjour Katia nous accueillons
aujourd'hui Jérôme Durand bonjour vous
êtes sénateur socialiste de
Saône-et-Loire et vice-président de la
commission des Lois du Sénat
et on va commencer Jérôme Durand par
cette image au Sénat Elisabeth borne qui
défend Éric Dupont-Moretti la première
ministre était interpellé sur le renvoi
du garde des sceaux devant la Cour de
Justice de la République
au menu du Parlement le projet de loi
sur la sécurité intérieure les sénateurs
de droite majoritaires ont durci le
texte présenté par Gérald Darmanin
et puis débat très tendu à l'Assemblée
nationale sur le projet de loi relatif à
l'assurance chômage un amendement a
notamment été voté pour assimiler les
abandons de poste à des démissions
on va d'abord évoquer cette rentrée
parlementaire agitée cette semaine dans
le contexte de la faire Dupont-Moretti
le Garde des Sceaux est renvoyé devant
la Cour de Justice de la République pour
briser les gags d'intérêt et au
Parlement les oppositions de gauche
demandent sa démission on va écouter un
échange mercredi au Sénat lors des
questions au Gouvernement entre la
première ministre Elisabeth borne et le
président du groupe du groupe écologiste
au Sénat Guillaume Gontard
la République exemplaire est de devenue
la République des affaires cette semaine
un nouveau cap a été franchi avec hormis
la mise en examen du secrétaire général
de Nizet une première et le renvoi du
garde des sceaux devant la Cour de
Justice de la République une première
également alors madame la Première
ministre connaissant la probité qui est
la vôtre allez-vous enfin l'appliquer à
votre gouvernement je veux rappeler deux
éléments fondamentaux pour notre État de
droit le premier c'est l'indépendance de
la justice c'est un des piliers de notre
démocratie et le second c'est la
présomption d'innocence l'engagement du
ministre est résolu solide et
indéfectible et pour les dossiers ou
Eric dupaume Moretti est un justiciable
comme les autres ou pour ceux qui la pu
connaître en tant qu'avocat nous avons
mis en place un dispositif de déport il
est exigeant il est efficace il me
conduit à piloter en direct une série de
sujets je vous remercie
Jérôme Durand est-ce que vous aussi vous
demandez la démission du ministre de la
Justice non je ne demande pas la
démission du ministre de la Justice en
revanche je constate que la République
exemplaire a vécu
en fait c'est sans doute on s'éloignant
du débat
parlementaire et de sa très grande
vivacité qu'on a le meilleur regard les
observateurs étrangers sont consternés
d'observer la situation et dans beaucoup
d'autres pays dans beaucoup d'autres
grandes démocratie les ministres
concernés ce qu'on parle du ministre
Dupont-Moretti qui n'est pas n'importe
quel ministre les ministres la justice
mais dans cette affaire il y a une
double affaire puisqu'il y a aussi le
secrétaire général de l'Elysée
ça finit par faire beaucoup et
finalement c'est le renoncement à la
République exemplaire et Emmanuel Macron
qui est pris en à son propre jeu c'est
l'arroser c'est-à-dire qui on allait
voir comment ça allait se passer c'était
une grande révolution des mœurs
politiques résultat pshit pour bien
comprendre ce que vous dites Jérôme
Durand on va rappeler rapidement la
faire le ministre est accusé d'avoir
lancé des enquêtes administratives à
l'EN de certains magistrats avec qui il
avait des contentieux à l'époque où il
était avocat et vous dites non je ne
demande pas sa démission donc pour vous
il reste présumé innocent non mais c'est
à lui de procédé que c'est pas nous la
question n'est pas posée à nous elle est
posée à ceux qui ont fait l'apologie
d'une république nouvelle de nouvelles
pratiques politiques et on ne comprend
pas ce que veut on ne comprend pas ce
que veut Emmanuel Macron d'ailleurs ni
sur ce sujet là ni sur beaucoup d'autres
on a toujours ce sentiment de flottement
et s'il a une courte très courte
majorité à l'Assemblée si ce quinquennat
par difficilement c'est aussi à cause de
ce comportement on annonce des choses on
fait l'inverse c'est c'est pareil sur
plein de sujets et donc en matière de
mœurs politique en matière de pratique
politique c'est déplorable pour nous
tous parce que toute la démocratie
toutes nos institutions représentatives
sont affectées donc il faut un petit peu
de clarté un peu de cohérence et je
pense que c'est ce que tout le monde
attend mais la première ministre le dit
l'essentiel c'est que le ministre de la
Justice ne soit pas entravé dans de son
action dans cette affaire vous êtes
d'accord mais est-ce que ça vous
convainc vous voyez bien que on a une
ligne de défense du gouvernement qui
aussi entre
l'indépendance de la justice la
séparation des pouvoirs la présomption
d'innocence et le complot politique
c'est-à-dire que les cadres macronistes
disent indépendance de la justice sont
au-dessus de la mêlée et toute la troupe
hurle au complot politique c'est
scandaleux c'est ce sont les magistrats
qui en veulent Eric Dupond-Moretti
Eric Dupond-Moretti paye un peu sans
doute aussi son humoriste à lui et ses
excès sont tempérament donc c'est pas
lui qui est en cause au fond vous
expliquer en tout cas je je pense que le
sujet c'est que quand on énonce des
principes c'est mieux de s'y tenir on a
connu d'autres époques ou même à
l'Élysée des gens démissionné pour moins
que ça donc il me semble que dans la
période c'est pas un sujet personnel
c'est pas un sujet moral c'est un sujet
principal et un autre point qui pose
question dans cette affaire c'est que
Eric Dupont-Moretti pourrait être amené
à nommer son propre accusateur en
l'occurrence le procureur en général de
la Cour de cassation qui est remplacé en
2023 c'est une situation qui est tenable
selon vous avez tout dit c'est c'est
quasi mécanique comment imaginer que un
ministre de la Justice renvoyé devant la
Cour de Justice de la République puisse
nommer celui qui peut être son
accusateur ça n'est pas possible ça
devrait des facto appeler une réaction
de l'intéresser donc cette situation
intenable c'est le le summum du conflit
d'intérêt et c'est un empêchement majeur
au sens républicain du terme on est même
plus dans la politique dans la mécanique
institutionnelle on devrait pas avoir à
se poser ces questions là ça devrait
être de plein droit là on parlait aussi
de ceux d'autres affaires Alexis colère
qui avait mis en examen pour priser
légal d'intérêt c'est toi c'est dans le
cadre de l'information judiciaire visant
ces liens familiers et professionnel
avec l'armateur MSC est-ce qu'il doit
quitter l'Élysée c'est un homme puissant
avec scolaire
il y a un patron puisqu'on parle
d'entreprise n'ont pas aimé c'est mais
donc de partir bah écoutez c'est le
principal collaborateur le jumeau dit-on
d'Emmanuel Macron il faut qu'il prenne
ses responsabilités mais là encore on
revient au principe la République
exemplaire tout tout personne en examen
doit démissionner tout ministre ça
n'avait déjà pas été le cas avec Alain
Griset si on se souvient bien puisqu'il
est parti que quand il a été condamné
voilà donc énoncé des principes
extrêmement martiaux et y revenir
ensuite comme ça un peu
manière rampante c'est pas à la hauteur
des enjeux allez on passe au premier
texte de la rentrée pour les sénateurs
le projet de loi locmi projet de loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur il prévoit
notamment une hausse des effectifs à des
forces de l'ordre sur les cinq
prochaines années avant le débat dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat ce mardi et bien
les sénateurs de la commission des lois
ont examiné ce texte et ils ont apporté
plusieurs modifications on va regarder
ce sujet de Cécile Sixou
pour mieux sécuriser les grands
événements et lutter contre la
cybercriminalité le gouvernement met les
moyens son projet de loi sécurité dit
loi l'opmi prévoit 15 milliards d'euros
de budget supplémentaires en 5 ans pour
les forces de l'ordre et la création de
8500 postes de policiers et gendarmes
dont 3000 dès l'an prochain pour le
ministre Géral de Darmanin l'objectif
est de mettre dans la rue deux fois plus
de force de l'ordre la police la
gendarmerie depuis au moins les
attentats terroristes 2015 est une
police qui fonctionne beaucoup en
intervention et qui mériterait sans
doute de se voir améliorer dans sa
présence de voies publiques nous voyons
que notamment ces indicateurs de
violence faite aux personnes
continuellement et surtout depuis le
covid celle-ci augmente sans doute par
manque de présence de voie publique des
policiers et des gendarmes au Sénat la
commission des lois salue le déploiement
de ses moyens pour les forces de l'ordre
mais estime qu'il faut aller plus loin à
partir du moment où vous mettez des
moyens supplémentaires sur la police et
sur les sur l'allègement des procédures
il faut que de manière stéréophonique
que vous ayez une une concomitance pour
qu'on ait une procédure qui est en face
soit utile c'est pour ça que j'ai
présenté un amendement qui sanctionne
beaucoup plus fort les violences faites
aux élus plus 47 % en an et refus
d'obtempérer plus 17% en an et les rodés
ou urbains qui sont quand même le
feuilleton du quotidien que voit nos
concitoyens pour les violences faites
aux élus les sénateurs prévoient 5 ans
de prison et 75000 euros d'amende le
refus d'obtempérer serait puni de trois
ans de prison et 30 000 euros enfin les
rodéo urbains passeraient d'un an de
prison à 5 et 75000 euros d'amende
contre 15000 euros actuellement autre
changement le gouvernement voulait
généraliser les amendes forfaitaires
délictuelles des contraventions pour
délit punies de moins d'un an de prison
comme la consommation de cannabis ou la
détention d'armes mais beaucoup de
délinquance ont un solvables les
sénateurs ont donc restreint leur champ
d'application la loi sera exam en séance
publique à partir du 11 octobre
Jérôme Durand vous suivez ce texte pour
le groupe socialiste au Sénat d'abord un
mot sur le grand objectif créer 8500
postes de policier de gendarmes pour les
5 prochaines années et ce que les
socialistes pourraient voter ce projet
de loi il y a plusieurs dimensions dans
le texte qui nous est présenté c'est une
aide orientation de programmation pour
le ministère de l'Intérieur qui ne
concerne d'ailleurs que la dimension
sécurité ministère de l'intérieur c'est
aussi les préfectures et là il y a
beaucoup de choses à dire sur les titres
d'identité bon on est sur la partie
sécurité police gendarmerie
la partie programmation la partie
budgétaire 15 milliards sur 5 ans c'est
difficile de dire dans un contexte
national ou la population est très
attachée aux questions de sécurité très
inquiète de ces questions de dire non
non ça nous intéresse pas évidemment que
c'est bon à prendre 200 brigades de
gendarmerie 8500 fonctionnaires en plus
c'est intéressant et je pense que en
responsabilité nous soutenons cette
partie là cette partie budgétaire il
faut après que ce soit honoré que la
programmation soit constatée budget
après budget mais sur cet aspect là nous
sommes favorables après il y a une
dimension d'orientation avec un rapport
annexé qui est assez touffu il faut
aussi regarder le rapport d'accès qui
parle de beaucoup de choses et puis
quelques aspects normatifs sur les
questions notamment de cybersécurité sur
toutes les nouvelles technologies sur
les AFD ça devient plus compliqué les
amandes délictuelle voilà et là sur ces
points là sur ces points là nous avons
quelques réserves tout de même vous
faites partie de la commission des lois
où il y a dans cette commission des des
sénateurs notamment de droite et du
centre qui ont durci un peu le texte
présenté le texte initial du
gouvernement on retire le divertissement
des peines pour trois délits d'abord les
violences faites aux élus les rodéo
urbains et enfin les refus d'obtempérer
est-ce que sur les refus d'obtempérer
qui font l'actualité vous trouvez que
c'est une bonne chose de durcir les
peines Jérôme Durand non si on veut
rendre justice au travail des deux
rapporteurs
il faut d'abord dire que ils ont plutôt
[Musique]
polissé arrondi lycée le texte et sur un
certain nombre de mesures on est plutôt
un peu en dessous donc ils ne l'ont pas
durci pour vous si ils ont durci avec
cette amendement 99 qui a déposé Marc
Philippe daubrais et qui concerne trois
sujets qui sont bien distincts sur la
question des violences faites aux élus
ont fait on s'aligne sur le régime qui
est applicable à toutes les personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique donc
ça ça nous va ça ça nous va mettre dans
le même amendement et on a demandé
d'ailleurs à ce que l'amendement soit
scindée en trois la question des rodéo
urbains sur laquelle on délibère
tous les ans avec une efficacité
relative nous paraissait pas de bonne
aloi sur les refus d'obtempérer il y a
évidemment de tempérer plus 17% nous
dit-on mais on a aussi
l'usage des armes à feu dans ce cas là
qui augmente de façon beaucoup plus
importante avec une étude qui est parue
il y a dix jours qui indiquent quand
même qu'on a une on a une des polices
qui tire le plus et qui tue le plus donc
sur ce sujet là il va vraiment va
falloir avoir un travail de fond et il
nous paraissait pas raisonnable de mêler
les trois sujets dans un amendement de
nature différente donc on reviendra à
nous en séance avec des amendements
dessus pression pour les deux autres
aspects qui nous paraissent pas
opportun sous la forme actuelle
précisément sur ces refus d'obtempérer
on le voit il y a des drames toutes les
semaines avec cette semaine une jeune
femme à Grenoble qui a été tué après un
refus d'obtempérer pour vous quelle est
la solution si on durcit pas la peine et
ce qu'il faut changer la doctrine
d'intervention des policiers il y a
évidemment un travail de fond opéré
ne nous faites pas dire vous ne le fait
vous ne le faites pas mais je vois bien
ce qu'on va nous renvoyer évidemment la
gauche les socialistes sont angéliques
ils ont toujours une propension à ne pas
défendre les policiers nous sommes du
côté des forces de l'ordre c'est-à-dire
que on veut que les gendarmes et les
policiers puissent se défendre mais il y
a un sujet quand même de vie humaine
perdu même si ce sont des gens qui ont
déjà fait des fautes même si ce sont des
gens qui sont fichés connus des services
politiques de police on ne tue pas
punément donc il faut qu'on s'intéresse
au fond sur la doctrine sur les moyens
moi j'avais interpellé le ministre lors
d'une réunion sur le sujet il faut qu'on
trouve d'autres solutions parce que
c'est inquiétant et je pense que très
profondément politiquement dans le pays
c'est de nature à conforter ceux qui
disent et nous ne sommes pas de cela la
police tue donc attention sur le le les
relations police population ce sujet des
refus d'obtempérer il est très important
on va passer à un autre thème Jérôme
Duras c'est le premier texte de la
session ordinaire ouverte mardi 4
octobre les députés ont examiné un
projet de loi mesure d'urgence pour le
travail il prolonge notamment les
nouvelles règles de l'assurance chômage
en modulant la durée de l'indemnisation
en fonction de la conjoncture en
attendant une réforme plus large
explication Stéphanie Despierres
c'est un changement de philosophie le
gouvernement veut moduler les droits au
chômage en fonction de la conjoncture
économique objectif combler les pénuries
de main d'oeuvre en clair quand les
offres d'emploi sont nombreuses les
conditions d'indemnisation seraient plus
strictes inciter les actifs à retrouver
un emploi plus rapidement plus
rapidement qu'aujourd'hui alors que de
nombreuses opportunités existent ce
n'est pas jeté le propre sur eux ça
n'est pas les culpabiliser ou un léguer
certains profitent du système les
chômeurs sont pointés du doigt et
stigmatiser érigé en bouc émissaire
pourtant plus de six chômeurs sur 10 ne
sont pas indemnisés les députés ont
validé le principe d'une modulation de
la durée d'indemnisation les critères
eux seront définis un prêt discussion
entre partenaires sociaux et
gouvernement autre sujet de friction
dans l'hémicycle les abandons de poste
selon le patronat leur nombre explose
mais aucun chiffre officiel n'est
disponible les républicains soutenus par
la majorité
veulent supprimer les allocations
chômage après un abandon de poste
l'assurance chômage est exclusivement
limité au cas de privation involontaire
d'emploi l'abandon de poste c'est un
abandon volontaire d'emploi nous ne
privons les salariés avec cet amendement
d'aucun droit ils ont toujours la
possibilité d'un recours s'il considère
que cet abandon de poste est une
démission forcée ce que vous nous
demandez aujourd'hui d'acter c'est le
fait que des salariés qui peuvent être
humiliés sous-payés et maltraités soient
maintenu en poste de gré ou de force
notamment pour des personnes qui si
elles ou ils portent plainte seront
blacklistés pour des années nous
retrouvons plus jamais de boulot dans le
secteur où les employeurs sont amenés à
se parler et à échanger une fois adopté
par le Parlement cette nouvelle réforme
de l'assurance chômage devrait entrer en
vigueur début 2023
Jérôme Durand le ministre du Travail
explique que la logique de ce texte
c'est de baisser les allocations chômage
quand l'économie se porte plutôt bien et
au contraire de les augmenter quand
c'est la crise est-ce que vous comprenez
sa logique oui je la comprends et je
pense que d'ailleurs le système actuel
concours déjà à cela puisqu'on a un
dispositif global qui entre en déficit
quand il y en a besoin et qui revient à
l'équilibre quand les mauvais temps
économiques sont passés là on essaie de
transposer cette dimension contrat
cycliques puisque c'est un des termes
qui a été utilisé au niveau de chaque
individu or les déterminants qui pèsent
sur les individus sur les gens qui
veulent travailler ils sont beaucoup
plus complexes là on était tout à
l'heure sur un débat sur la sécurité qui
était assez nuancé là on a perdu toute
nuance on est dans la bonne grosse
politique épaisse un peu facile et dans
quelque chose qui est de l'ordre de la
stigmatisation des chômeurs alors même
qu'on se rencontre que s'agissant du
recours à l'assurance chômage dans 25 à
42% des cas il n'est effectif donc les
gens ne
n'utilisent même pas le dispositif alors
même qu'on sait que ce qui empêche
d'aller travailler c'est des questions
de santé de mobilité de compétences de
garde d'enfants donc c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que cette espèce de caricature
très droitière qu'on essaie de nous
faire avaler avec laquelle je suis
totalement en désaccord et pourtant en
ce moment il y a une grave crise de
recrutement énormément de secteurs dans
l'économie peine à pourvoir certains
postes est-ce que le fait de durcir les
règles de la sur en chômage dans cette
période ça pourrait pas être une
solution on l'a fait une dernière est-ce
que ça a marché non il y a 350 365 000
postes à pourvoir il y a 5,9 millions de
personnes qui sont sans emploi on sait
que c'est une étude de la DARES qui le
dit que dans un tiers des cas il s'agit
d'un problème de compétence c'est pas ce
que vous remettez quelqu'un sur le
marché du travail que vous arrêtez de
l'indemnité de l'indemniser s'il ne sait
pas faire un travail il va pas savoir
refaire pour autant dans un quart des
cas c'est un sujet de déficit
d'attractivité des métiers parce qu'ils
sont mal payés ils sont mal considérés
les salariés sont mal considérés dans
beaucoup de fonctions ouvriers non
qualifiées dans l'agroalimentaire donc
ça n'est pas en utilisant le bâton qu'on
va arriver à remettre les gens de
travail et donc c'est cette bonne
vieille
ritournelle de les gens sont fainéants
ils s'habituent au confort quand on a
pas de boulot excusez moi on n'est pas
dans le confort donc je pense que là il
y a un vrai sujet politique ça
n'affichage c'est sans doute aussi un
bon moyen pour
la majorité de Monsieur Macron d'aller
chercher des appuis du côté à droite
alors justement les députés ont voté des
amendements notamment venus de la droite
qui assimile un abandon de poste à une
démission sofraestception cela
évidemment déclenché on l'a vu la bronca
sur les rangs de la gauche est-ce que
pour vous c'est un cadeau du
gouvernement au député LR pour s'assurer
de leur vote sur ce texte oui oui ce
côté stigmatisant brimmatoire est un
marqueur offert est un signal envoyé à
la droite on parlait tout à l'heure de
la sécurité avec un abandon qui posait
problème dans la période chacun essaie
de conforter ses positions en plus il y
a un congrès politique à droite donc je
pense que tout le monde y trouve
avantage et qu'effectivement pour
Emmanuel Macron c'est le maintien c'est
le moyen de trouver une majorité donc
c'est évidemment un signal politique
finalement dans ce débat il y a deux
visions du travail qui s'affrontent et
qui peut qui peuvent également diviser
la gauche est-ce que vous vous êtes
satisfait par cette séparation cette
division qui avait été faite par Fabien
Roussel entre d'un côté à la gauche du
travail et la gauche des allocs c'est un
débat extrêmement intéressant il a été
réduit à une opposition frontale que
nous nous intéressions en ce début de
21e siècle sur le sens du travail sur le
sens de l'activité sur la nature des
revenus c'est extrêmement
riche et je pense que c'est notre
travail politique de faire ça et
d'ailleurs quand on dit c'est le travail
ou les allocs euh la réalité c'est que
il y a des allocations qui sont
institutionnellement
convoqué pour compléter les revenus
d'activité ça existe déjà donc les
frontières elles sont sans doute plus
plus fines plus délicates
donc sortons du débat simpliste mais en
revanche il faut qu'on ait ce débat mais
si on l'a en disant les chômeurs sont
des fainéants alors vraiment on passe à
côté alors l'essentiel est-ce que vous
reconnaissez quand même Gérôme Durand à
Emmanuel Macron d'avoir réduit le
chômage à
7,3%, il était à plus de 10% sous
François Hollande oui mais bon il y a
des effets de conjoncture c'est une
bonne nouvelle le but du jeu n'est pas
de dire que le président échoue pour
tout en tout cas je pense que
philosophiquement et dans les rapports
sociaux le sujet de la période c'est les
inégalités il y a des gens qui sont en
très grande souffrance et alors même que
d'autres se remplissent les poches on a
parlé des super profitsellectualité et
dire que ceux qui sont en bas de
l'échelle sont forcément des feignants
et qui leur situation ça me paraît très
grave pour la cohésion sociale un
problème de répartition d'inégalités
vous dites alors on va jeter un coup
d'oeil rapide au point chaud de l'agenda
parlementaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et mardi au Sénat ce sera donc le début
de l'examen en hémicycle du projet de
loi loop me d'orientation et de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur le lendemain il aura un
débat sur la politique énergétique de la
France organisée à la demande du
gouvernement dans le contexte de la
crise de l'énergie qu'on connaît et puis
à l'Assemblée nationale la grande
journée ce sera lundi avec le coup
d'envoi du débat budgétaire en séance
publique c'est à 16h grand moment de la
vie parlementaire et cette année le
débat promet d'être rude le gouverneur
le gouvernement menaçant de recourir au
49.3 s'il n'a pas la majorité et aussi
toujours lundi double dose de budget
puisque le projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale et lui au menu en
commission Jérôme Durand on a choisi de
vous interroger de poser une petite
question très simple sur ce budget 2023
peut-il y avoir une coalition des
oppositions dont vous êtes sur ce budget
en tout cas là on parle plutôt de
l'Assemblée nationale est-ce que vous
pensez que les oppositions peuvent
mettre le gouvernement un échec sur le
budget côté la première partie a été
adoptée cette semaine hier soir donc
dans des conditions d'ailleurs de
présence dans l'hémicycle qui dont je ne
sais pas si elles sont un signe
politique ou pas je crois qu'il faut
qu'on se détermine chaque fois tout le
monde en fait vous dites donc je pense
que ce qui est important là c'est qu'on
puisse plutôt travailler sur le fond et
défendre les idées qui nous sont chères
moi je la préoccupation des Français
c'est la solidarité l'étude fracture
française qui vient d'être publié le dit
c'est la question de la santé c'est la
peur du déclassement donc le PLF projet
de loi de finances ça doit être un acte
de solidarité je pense que ce que c'est
c'est la gauche de défendre ça avant
tout si le gouvernement passe en force
sur ce budget s'il n'a pas de majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale et qui l'utilise
l'article 49-3 de la Constitution est-ce
que vous dites en tant que parlementaire
bien mes collègues députés socialistes
devraient voter la motion de censure de
gouvernement coûter chacun fera ce qu'il
a à faire il faut qu'on voit les termes
du débat à ce moment-là contiennent bon
sur nos positions
dont j'ai rappelé que la question des
inégalités étaient centrales je pense
que c'est vraiment
la loupe au travers de laquelle on doit
regarder la situation du pays on verra
sur la procédure dont tout le monde nous
dit qu'elle est compliquée est-ce que ça
va arriver au Sénat dans quelles
conditions après 49,3 pas 49,3 ça on
verra ce moment-là en tout cas sur la
politique je pense qu'il faut tenir bon
sur ces valeurs oui mais on parle que ça
convient de 49,3 quel moment quand
est-ce que les les oppositions vont
s'organiser pour essayer de s'entendre
sur motion vous en tant que sénateur
quel regard vous vous portez sur ce qui
peut se passer à l'Assemblée comme vous
voyez les choses je pense très longtemps
qu'on n'a pas utilisé de 49,3 sur un
budget depuis Michel Rocard je pense que
enfin moi je vois les choses depuis le
terrain
je vois des gens qui font les gens font
la queue aux stations-service pour leur
naissance ils sont très inquiets de
de leurs revenus de leur pouvoir d'achat
des questions qui vont se poser très
concrètement sur leur budget et tout ce
qui le concours à renvoyer un sentiment
de confusion dans le travail
parlementaire est mauvais pour
l'équilibre social et pour la cohésion
du pays et les tensions dures on a
d'ailleurs plutôt tendance à leur
demander de de
contribuer volontairement aux questions
de sobriété donc on fait appel à leur
sens des responsabilités donc je pense
que notre travail parlementaire il doit
renvoyer ça aussi et on peut être en
désaccord on peut affirmer des valeurs
différentes et moi je pense que nos
valeurs de gauche elles sont importantes
de la période mais si on peut se
départir de cette position un peu
confuse tout le débat public il gagnera
pour rapidement est-ce que la nuque
participe de cette confusion du travail
parlementaire notamment la France
insoumise je crois pas qu'il faille
stigmatiser les uns ou les autres le la
rentrée parlementaire et et le résultat
des élections législatives au sein de
l'hémicycle à l'Assemblée nationale a
contribué à un bois collectif stigmatisé
l'un plutôt que l'autre me paraît
injuste et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci beaucoup d'y avoir
participé comme du Rhin et merci à tous
de l'avoir suivi et ce week-end c'est le
pasteur don vous pouvez faire vos dons
pour la recherche
pasteurdon.fr ou au 36-20 ciao ciao
[Musique]